CBS this morning partners with the
professional networking site to LinkedIn
for our continuing series work in
progress we explore the future of jobs
and the issues facing the American
workforce this morning we're looking at
the growing shortage of truck drivers
more than 70% of the goods we consume
are carried on the nation's highways a
new report says the industry needs to
hire roughly 90,000 new truckers each
year to keep up with demand Kris Van
Cleave shows us why so many of those
jobs are unfilled and how it would drive
up cost for you the American trucker
carries our country nothing we get isn't
touched by a truck
they say truckers drive the American
economy if that's the case we could be
in trouble
50,000 more drivers are needed by the
end of 2017 and that number could more
than triple in 10 years when we're
buying more stuff out there with us cars
frigerators you name it we're putting
that in trucks and that's gonna
exacerbate the shortage that we have Bob
Costello is the chief economist for the
industry trade group American Trucking
associations once we hit that hundred
thousand mark I think that's where we
start to see problems throughout the
economy problems like product shortages
delivery delays and higher prices
demographics are largely behind the
shortfall but the lifestyle including
extended periods away from home can also
be a major deterrent there's a sense
that people just don't want to be truck
drivers why do you think that is it's a
hard life I mean you know I got a
36-inch box that I'm sleeping in in the
back of my truck most night you know I
get hotels from time to time but you've
got to want to do it you know you've got
to want to be able to travel go
different places see different things
and you know deal with different people
every day let me fix something we let
Greg Edinburgh waiting for his rig to be
repaired at Iowa 80 the world's largest
truck stop outside Davenport Iowa he's
made life on the road work for his
family and that gives him and drivers
like Jennifer Gossman a lot of
bargaining power how hard was it to find
a truck driver job
it was just a matter of making phone
calls and seeing what company is you
know works around what you want you know
your home time here the pay you know how
long you have to be out there's
companies that you know when you first
start you have to be out there for six
months I didn't want that I OAD doesn't
typically allow recruiters here at the
truck stop because they fear it would
turn into a bit of a frenzy instead once
a year they hold a trucker's Jamboree
where recruiters are allowed to come in
this year more than 44,000 people
attended we found real recruiter great
keppel at the great American Truck Show
in Dallas the employment market for
truck drivers is what I would call hyper
competitive and we feel it every day we
always say yesterday was our easiest day
his company hopes to attract new drivers
including Millennials by paying them to
get a commercial driver's license and
complete on-the-job training many
drivers tell us it comes down to one
thing I think if they want to hire more
drivers they're gonna have to increase
the pack fleets are raising wages and
offering incentives to attract drivers
but pressure to keep shipping costs down
has also put a damper on compensation
LinkedIn is chip cutter if you look at
the federal data a truck driver in 2006
was actually making more than he or she
will be making in 2016 if you factor in
the cost of living it's a couple hundred
dollar difference but still it shows
that wages really have not meaningfully
increased to address the shortage that
data puts a median driver pay just over
41,000 dollars still many see trucking
as a road to a better life the industry
just needs to convince tens of thousands
more to hit the road for CBS this
morning Kris Van Cleave Wolcott Iowa I
think there will always be a need for
truck drivers one truck driver told me
this once I've never forgotten it when
you look around your room in your house
and your job there's nothing in this
place that didn't get here without a
truck yeah this is out a truck driver at
some point as they say essential to our
economy that's right they should very
well-paid